cbs news projects governor gavin newsom
has survived an attempt to recall him
from office so far more than 63 percent
of voters say they want him to stay on
as governor of their state rather than
be replaced now the ballots are still
being counted at this hour major garrett
is in sacramento with more on the story
major good morning to you
good morning gayle good morning everyone
from sacramento on sunday in los angeles
i asked governor newsom if the recall
election had taught him anything he said
every elected official who had to make
decisions during the pandemic about
lockdowns vaccines social distancing
schools had been scrutinized and
criticized and the governor told me he'd
made mistakes but now newsome has
something those other elected officials
don't have vindication because this
recall election in the end was a
referendum on his pandemic policies and
the result was a blowout
no is not the only thing
that was expressed tonight governor
gavin newsom decisively defeated a
recall effort sparked in part by his
lockdown and mandate approach to dealing
with a pandemic i want to focus on what
we said yes to as a state we said yes to
science we said yes to vaccines we said
yes to ending this pandemic most voters
said the governor's policies were about
right rather than too strict and
coronavirus was the most important issue
for those voting to keep newsom in
office but among those who voted to oust
the governor the economy and
homelessness topped the list
newsome raised about 70 million dollars
to fight the recall roughly six times
the total of conservative radio talk
show host and gop front-runner larry
elder we recognize
that we lost the battle but we are
certainly going to win the war that war
could be california's next gubernatorial
election in just 14 months a race that
may against his elder against newsom
let me just say this
stay tuned
newsome who drew support from prominent
democrats spent the home stretch of the
campaign tying elder to former president
donald trump a deeply unpopular figure
in california and it seems to have
worked i'm humbled
and grateful to the millions and
millions of californians that exercise
their fundamental right to vote and
express themselves so overwhelmingly by
rejecting the division
elder had toyed with the idea filing
legal challenges against the recall
results arguing without any evidence
whatsoever that fraud might tip the
scales well newsome's landslide buried
that notion elder said last night i lost
and he urged his supporters to accept
defeat graciously tony
if you're going to win it helps to win
by a lot major thank you very much